here's my morning must read just a
portion of everybody should read this on
global Wall Street out worldwide Buffett
mr. Trump stated that mr. Buffett took a
massive deduction mr. Buffett states I
have paid federal income tax every year
since before any of us were born when I
was 13 though being a slow starter I
owed only seven dollars in tax in 1944 I
have no problem in leasing releasing my
tax information while under audit
neither would mr. Trump at least he
would have no legal problem Francine
this was an extraordinary response as I
said yesterday out in Twitter
good morning noon and night
extraordinary statement by mr. Buffett
yeah you're absolutely right and then we
have also you know today I guess the
split continues certainly when you look
at what Paul Ryan is doing and at the
same time time we have a great great
story saying Donald Trump wants to run
America like a businessman imagine if a
CEO of a footsie 100 company of welcome
came out with what he did in in that
video and how he would be treated and
with us Jerry webmin of Oppenheimer jury
you grown up on the right side of the
tracks like a lot of us fortunate enough
to pay you know to visit one example
alternative minimum tax that's a big day
that first year you do AMT we forget how
much the top 10% the top 15% of America
pony up all the attentions on a guy like
Trump I think that's right I listen I do
we you know I pay taxes you pay taxes it
the tax system I mean one of the things
that I would love to hear in this debate
that they're not hearing which probably
ought to be coming from a Paul Ryan is
let's clean up this tax code so that we
get rid of all the disorders of trust
back and get some trust back so we all
kind of know we're paying our fares
nobody can claim I'm not paying what's
important about this as it goes back to
Reagan and Tip O'Neill I'm gonna guess
1986 but I may be off by 10 years is a
primal scream for tax reform in Francine
as you saw on Sunday they're nowhere
close and they're just
we're closed no there no more closed but
actually Jerry just going back to the
policies right of both candidates we
know that both candidates are flawed for
different reasons but actually what do
we actually know about what kind of
policies they'll put in place so Donald
Trump is flip-flopping for example an
austerity or spending and then Hillary
Clinton is saying one things to bankers
and is telling the people another thing
yeah yeah I think that what we you know
86 is a very interesting story because
we set out to simplify the tax code in
1986 we remember Bill Bradley we should
be able to pay it on the back of a net
out of a postcard we actually expanded
the tax code in nineteen it more
complicated in 1986